[Música]
en 1800 el explorador Alexander Von
Humboldt vio varias anguilas eléctricas
saliendo del agua para defenderse de
unos caballos
la mayoría de las personas creyeron que
Humboldt inventó la historia pero los
peces eléctricos son más usuales de lo
que creemos Y sí las anguilas eléctricas
son un tipo de pez debajo del agua donde
la luz es escasa las señales eléctricas
son una forma de comunicación navegación
y en algunos casos extraños aturdimiento
de la presa
cerca de 350 especies de peces tienen
estructuras especializadas en generar o
detectar señales eléctricas
estos peces están divididos en dos
grupos según cuanta electricidad
producen los científicos llaman al
primer grupo Los peces de Electricidad
débil las estructuras cerca de la cola
llamadas órganos eléctricos producen
hasta dos tercios del potencial de una
batería aa
Cómo funcionan el cerebro del pez Envía
una señal a través del sistema nervioso
al órgano eléctrico que está lleno de
pilas de cientos o miles de células con
forma de disco llamadas electrocitos
normalmente los eritrocitos liberan
iones de sodio y potasio para mantener
una carga positiva externa y una carga
negativa interna Pero cuando la señal
nerviosa llega al electrocito permite el
flujo de iones
los iones positivos fluyen al interior
ahora un lado del eritrocito tiene carga
negativa externa y carga positiva
interna pero el lado opuesto tiene la
carga opuesta estas cargas alternas
pueden conducir una corriente
convirtiendo al electrocito en una
batería biológica la clave del poder de
los peces son las señales coordinadas
del nervio para llegar a cada célula al
mismo tiempo
esto genera que los grupos de
electrocitos actúen como miles de
baterías en serie las pequeñas cargas de
cada uno se acumulan en un campo
eléctrico que puede viajar varios metros
las células llamadas electrorreceptores
al fondo de la piel le permiten al pez
sentir este campo y los cambios
generados por el entorno u otro pez por
ejemplo el pez de nariz elefante tiene
un mentón a largo llamado el órgano de
schnauzen que está lleno de
electrorreceptores esto le recibir
señales de otro pez medir distancias
detectar forma y tamaño de objeto
cercanos e incluso determinar si un
insecto enterrado está vivo o muerto
pero el pez nariz elefante y otros de
Electricidad débil no producen
suficiente electricidad para atacar a su
presa esta capacidad la tienen los peces
de Electricidad fuerte de los cuales
solo Hay pocas especies el pez eléctrico
más poderoso es el pez cuchillo
eléctrico
comúnmente llamado anguila eléctrica
tres órganos eléctricos cubren casi todo
su cuerpo de dos metros la anguila
eléctrica también usa sus señales para
navegación y comunicación pero guarda la
descarga eléctrica más fuerte para cazar
usando un ataque en dos fases para
ubicar e incapacitar a su presa primero
emite dos o tres pulsos fuertes de hasta
600 voltios los cuales estimulan los
músculos para generarle espasmos y crear
ondas que revelan dónde está oculta
luego una descarga rápida de alto
voltaje causa contracciones musculares
mucho más intensas la anguila eléctrica
también se puede enrollar para que los
campos eléctricos al final de cada
órgano eléctrico se sobrepongan la
tormenta eléctrica al final cansa e
inmoviliza a la presa y la anguila
eléctrica puede comer su alimento vivo
los otros dos peces de Electricidad
fuertes son el pez gato eléctrico el
cual puede generar 350 voltios con un
órgano eléctrico que ocupa la mayor
parte del torso y la raya eléctrica con
órganos eléctricos en ambos lados de la
cabeza que producen hasta 220 voltios el
mundo de los peces eléctricos es
misterioso porque no se electrocutan
ellos mismos puede ser que el tamaño de
los peces eléctricos fuertes les permita
resistir su propia descarga o que la
corriente atraviese muy rápido su cuerpo
algunos científicos creen que algunas
proteínas especiales pueden cubrir los
órganos eléctricos pero aún existe un
misterio científico sin resolver
otro animal con propiedades únicas es el
pulpo cuyo cuerpo entero funciona como
un cerebro obtenga más información con
este video
[Música]